Unfortunately,
I think everyone thinks they're funny
maybe.
And so few people actually are,
I think there's a certain type of bully
humor,
bullies throughout history and including
people who have become some of the most
powerful people in the world.
You know,
they just use their humor to make other
people feel small and to be like every
joke they they make is at someone's
expense.
And um,
almost bragging about how much more
powerful they are then the other person.
And that to me is not the greatest sense
of humor to have because um,
while it's fun to slam your friends,
I think,
um,
you really don't have a lot of empathy
for the,
for the bully who's using humor.
I think the instinct to be self
deprecating starts when you're young
and,
and you know,
you,
you don't take yourself too seriously
when you're not popular in the world and
your peers don't seem to be taking you
seriously.
You know,
I remember in high school for some
reason I just heard that there was a
huge dude who was,
who really didn't like me,
who wanted to beat me up as far as I was
concerned.
I had never met him,
but it was just one of those things
where he had found someone smaller than
him to pick on.
And so I remember just using humor to
disarm him and like he got in my face
one day and I just was like,
come on man.
I started,
I started acting like really huge and
tough.
I'm like,
come on,
I'll take you down.
Come on Bro.
Come at me Bro.
And he just started laughing and was
like,
Ha,
you're funny man.
And then after that we were friends.
I was getting mugged once and um,
I just ended up talking to the guy for
20 minutes and I'm trying to make him
laugh.
And at the end of it he was like,
ah,
you're too nice of a guy.
All right,
I'll see you later.
That's sort of skill,
um,
can really come in handy when you feel
as if the world is against you in a way
to not take yourself seriously.
I think the,
the,
the world then has empathy for you.
You always see it when you're taking a
public speaking class.
They always say,
start off with a joke.
Um,
you know,
it's,
people don't want to have lives where
they're sitting there being bored by
people all the time.
And you know,
when,
when you're in charge of a company,
people usually hate their boss because
they're mean all the time.
You know,
humor is a great tool to use to just get
people on your side.
Mm,
okay.